der grund warum ich in gesprächen mit
ihnen gebeten hat ist es ich gerade
umgezogen bin von berlin in die schweiz
und jetzt ist eine doppelfolge nach
basel
kerner und ich möchte jetzt eine art
doppelfolge machen einmal aus berlin wie
die deutschen die schweiz betrachten und
was sie für vorteile haben aber auch was
sie für gedanken haben was ihnen so
einfällt und dann werden wir in basel
das gleiche machen umgekehrt so zu sagen
und ich find's super spannend natürlich
zu hören
aus sicht einer botschafterin was man
sozusagen sagen kann über das verhältnis
zwischen den beiden ländern über die
vorteile diese dinge eben so also dass
zum groben weilheim zusammen aber da
dürfen wir schon loslegen oder was ist
sehr gut ich würde erst mal
interessieren wie man botschafterin wird
für ein land für die schweiz also wie
vielleicht können sie einen ganz groben
umrissen uhr geben über ihren lebenslauf
über ihre kindheit und wie sie jetzt
hier in diesem gebäude gelandet sind als
die voraussetzung ist ein
abgeschlossenes studium und dann noch
berufserfahrung
dann muss man aber einen test machen das
ist der diplomatische kongo und da
bewerben sich jeweils hunderte von
schweizerinnen und schweizern man muss
also schweizer sein und der goncourt
betrifft fragen zu politik zu
recht geschichte wirtschaft kultur
man muss mindestens zwei amtssprachen
können weil wir sprechen ja drei
sprachen plus noch eine vierte die aber
nicht eine amtssprache ist sondern einen
nationalsprache so werden 14
und wenn man das bestanden hat dann gibt
es eine zweijährige ausbildung und dann
gibt es noch eine abschlussprüfung und
dann wird man dann ins ausland versetzt
um dann gibt es ein 4 rhythmus von
versetzungen vier jahres rhythmus aber
man wird auch alle drei jahre wieder neu
qualifiziert und so gibt es immer wieder
die möglichkeit sich befördern zu lassen
und dann an der highlight der karriere
ist für viele dann eine mission selber
zu leiten also als botschafter ich habe
jetzt einen hintergrund dass sich jura
studiert habe und dann auch an einem
bezirksgericht in der schweiz gearbeitet
haben dann mit der prüfungs annahme
ziemlich rasch ins ausland versetzt
wurde und jetzt waren sie glaube ich in
anderen ländern schon relativ lange
wie kam es denn dazu dass sie nach
deutschland ins nachbarland direkt
gekommen sind also das entscheidet bei
uns eher als botschafter entscheidet
dass die regierung und mein
außenminister hat das gewünscht und ich
war natürlich sehr geehrt weil
deutschland ist einer unser ganz wichtig
oder wichtigsten partner es ist auch
unser wichtigster handelspartner und zur
miete ist deutschland für die schweiz
ganz ganz wichtig und das ist schon eine
große ehre dass man hier botschafterin
sein kann was ich finde das wort
botschaften oder den namen des berufs
eigentlich so schön ja sie bringen die
botschaften die die schweiz betreffen
nach deutschland und vielleicht auch
umgekehrt aber was wie kann ich es mir
spezifisch vorstellen was machen sie
morgens wie geht der tag los was ist ein
typischer tag was sind ihre aufgaben als
gut ich glaube daher gefällt mir der
beruf so jeder tag ist wieder anders wir
haben ein total breites spektrum
abzudecken
politik wirtschaft kultur handel
tourismus netzwerke bilden also das sind
ja die ist die themenvielfalt
daher ist keinen tag an gleich wieder
andere und da kommt es natürlich auf der
auf den einsatzort dann als zb in
thailand war ich ständig in einer
krisensituation also da gab es
gewaltsame demonstrationen militärputsch
da muss man sich ganz anders vorbereiten
und einrichten
hier sind jetzt in deutschland
bilaterale themen viel wichtiger weil
wir hier sehr viele delegationen aus der
schweiz empfangen und daher ist das
netzwerk so wichtig also ich bin jetzt
erst seit drei monaten hier und habe so
in der regel fünf antriebs besucher pro
tag damit ich sehr sehr viele leute
rasch kennen lernen damit ich die
zusammenbringen kann mit den schweizern
und sie dann eben wirklich über
fachthemen diskutieren können dann
natürlich muss sich auch die
berichterstattung machen also in die
schweiz was themen wie zb die
migrationspolitik interessiert natürlich
die kinder schweiz sehr genau was
deutschland dazu macht weil wir ja im
schengen raum genauso partizipieren
was sind denn so die heißen themen
zwischen diesen beiden ländern und jetzt
natürlich werden sie sagen vermutlich
das ist eine richtige freundschaft wir
sind wichtige handelspartner und so
weiter aber was sind denn so die
wirklich heißen themen die die beiden
länder ausmachen wo wir vielleicht auch
differenzen haben wo wir vielleicht
verbündet sind wo andere länder ganz
anderer meinung sind so was was würden
sie in dieser in dieser beziehung
deutschland schweiz als wichtig erachten
ja ich sage ihnen mal je näher man sich
ist und je ähnlicher und auch viele
gemeinsame themen hat desto mehr ist das
risiko natürlich auch da dass man dann
vielleicht differenzen ab je weiter man
weg ist gibt es fast keine
berührungspunkte mehr oder und daher ist
es ganz normal dass man auch punkte hat
die man aus diskutieren muss
und das ist im moment ein thema das uns
sehr beschäftigt ist
die masseneinwanderung initiative die
die schweiz schweizer bevölkerung
angenommen hat das war vor einem jahr
hat die schweizer bevölkerung die
mehrheit abgestimmt dass wir unsere
einwanderung selber steuern möchten und
das ist im widerspruch zum
personenfreizügigkeitsabkommen dass die
schweiz mit der eu hat und diese
umsetzung müssen wir bis februar 2017
erledigt haben und wenn wir das nicht
schaffen dann geht es in einer
verordnung einfach angewendet
das heißt wir müssen also jetzt die zeit
nutzen um eine möglichst praktikable
lösung zu finden
und das sind wir natürlich auch auf die
unterstützung unseres nachbarn
deutschland angewiesen
aber das ist nicht ein dickes problem
zwischen der schweiz und deutschland
weil das ist ein resultat einer
abstimmung die die schweizer so gewollt
haben also müssen jetzt schauen wie wir
da eine lösung finden dann gibt es noch
kleinere dossiers die zb der flughafen
in zürich da hat man einen staatsvertrag
gemacht vor drei jahren vier jahren
und der ist noch nicht unterzeichnet
oder ratifiziert von deutschland und da
hoffen wir dass wir da noch eine lösung
finden
ein anderes thema ist auch der
schienenverkehr hätten natürlich gerne
wenn die schweiz den transit macht durch
die alpen mit der nährt das ist der
gotthard-tunnel der dann alle güter
durch der schiene durch vom norden nach
süden bringen soll
der wird im ersten januar 2016 eröffnet
daher hoffen wir dass die die
schienenverkehr dann auch richtung
deutschland auf der die güter auf der
schiene transportiert werden können
und da hoffen wir dass deutschland da
auch
die infrastruktur dazu leistet wie wie
es denn dann ihre rolle in solchen
prozess mit einem solchen politischen
entscheidungen sind sie dann teil einer
politischen meinung in der schweiz oder
vertreten sie quasi alle politischen
meinungen in der schweiz oder die
aktuelle regierung oder ich mir das
vorstellen also ich vertrete er die
schweiz also in diesem sinne das was die
schweizer wollen und die das dass die
regierung und daher muss ich meine
private meinung dazu zurückstellen
aber natürlich kann man auch ideen
einbringen wie man ein problem oder ein
thema angeht und meine wichtigste arbeit
ist hier sicher türen zu öffnen brücken
zu bauen verständnis zu schaffen auf
beiden seiten und damit aber eben auch
eine lösungsfindung zu erleichtern
aber das ist je nach einsatzort ist der
kontext wieder ganz anders also wenn sie
in einem krisenland sind oder in einem
entwicklungsland
da können sie sicher noch mehr ideen
gegenüber der eigenen regierung
einbringen indem sie sagen
machen wir doch eine entwicklungsprojekt
in dieser dieser region oder zum
beispiel das ist ein problem im bereich
menschenhandel könnten wir dort eine
zusammenarbeit zur bekämpfung des
menschenhandels initiieren
da kann man sehr viele ideen einbringen
und dann wenn bern sagt ja ist eine gute
idee
wir geben das geld für dieses projekt
dann kann man das auch so umsetzen
jetzt hat sie gerade schon so ein paar
aspekte der direkten demokratie
angesprochen wie würden sie dieses
system was ja relativ einzigartig ist
auf der welt jemandem erklären da damit
der damit nichts zu tun hatte der ganz
neues was die schweiz betrifft also wir
sagen der souverän in der schweiz ist
das volk das heißt niemand anders
entscheidet über sachen als die
bevölkerung
und daher haben wir sehr viele
abstimmungen pro jahr
und über jegliche themen sein dass das
die ein initiativkomitee gebildet wird
und unterschriften auf der straße
sammelt und ich weiß nicht ob sie das in
der schweiz schon gesehen haben dass
leute mit unterschreiben sie man kommt
da schnell raus wenn man sagt ich bin
kein schweizer weil man dann sind sie
schon draußen aber wenn ja also dann
nimmt man sich auch die zeit also ist
ein schweizer läuft eigentlich kaum an
so einem unterschriften stand vorbei
weil er sich interessiert soll ich jetzt
unterschreiten oder nicht und oft kommen
initiativen zu stande und dann gibt es
halt eine abstimmung
und wenn die abstimmung hat über 50
prozent ja stimmen sind dann wird das
auch akzeptiert weil man weiß auch an
die mehrheit will dass auch wenn es
knapp ist
dann gibt es natürlich auch den anderen
weg dass die gesetze von der regierung
vorgeschlagen werden oder auch vom
parlament und dann durch das parlament
gehen muss und da ist auch ein sehr
demokratischer prozess weil zuerst macht
man ein vernehmlassungsverfahren also
man versucht alle interessierten
organisationen parteien institutionen
anzuschreiben und um ihre meinung zu
bieten über den gesetzesentwurf
und wenn der positiv ist mehrheitlich
dann geht er so ins parlament oder man
passt ihn noch an
oder wenn man sieht auf der ganzen
bandbreite gibt es keine zustimmung zu
diesem entwurf dann geht man besser noch
einmal über die bücher und erließ also
macht einen neuen entwurf und dann
geht's in den nationaler das ist dass
wir die grosse kammer mit 200 vertreten
sind die volksvertreter und dort wird
das auch in den verschiedenen
kommissionen behandelt und dann geht es
in den ständerat das ist die kleine
kammer mit 46 da sinkt die ständeräte
dass die vertreter der kantone
wenn beide zugestimmt haben dann wird
das gesetz kommt zustande
aber dann gibt es noch eine
referendumsfrist also jedes gesetz geht
muss eine frist durchlaufen bevor es in
kraft tritt
und wenn dann niemand das referendum
ergreift tritt in kraft und sonst wird
noch einmal darüber abgestimmt also
jedes gesetz in der schweiz kann man
davon ausgehen dass die bevölkerung das
so gewollt hat und bis es dann
entschlossen es muss eine ganze menge
kompromisse geschlossen werden in der
regel also direkte demokratie ist geht
nicht rasch es braucht viel zeit
viele prozesse aber wenn es dann hat man
zustande gekommen ist dann stehen alle
dahinter als gute beispiel jetzt wieder
mit diesem boot tunnel der 23 milliarden
schweizer franken gekostet hat da wo der
abgestimmt und die bevölkerung angesagt
doch diesen tunnel wollen wir und dann
wird er auch zügig gebaut und alle leute
stehen dahinter
ich kenne die geschichte von appen
zellen wo bis heute mit anhebung auf dem
marktplatz ja abgestimmt wird
wie also wie kommen solche lokalen
unterschiede zustande oder wie finden
sie das vielleicht auch also es ja schon
ein bisschen altmodisch vielleicht auch
ein bisschen ungenau
ja also das ist hat man nimmt rücksicht
auf die geografischen
unterschiedlichkeiten der region wir
sind ja auch ein land auf sehr kleinem
raum mit sehr vielen unterschiedlichen
kulturen und sprachen wir haben nicht
nur vier verschiedene sprachen sondern
auch religionsgemeinschaften traditionen
das ist auch von der topographie her so
gegeben dass die bergbevölkerung sicher
eine andere mentalität dass die
stadtbevölkerung in genf zürich oder
basel
und man nimmt darauf rücksicht und diese
landsgemeinde die sie erwähnen dass die
stadt eine sehr ursprüngliche form der
demokratie womit der hand abgestimmt
wird
wieso ist die schweiz international so
neutral oder hat den ruf so neutral zu
sein bis das zustande gekommen und javi
wie ist das heute wie äußert sich das
heute
heutigen politik und der heutige
weltlage es kommt schon aus der
geschichte dass wir wirklich die
neutralität erklärt haben und das auch
so immer noch praktizieren wir sagen
auch es gibt eine aktive neutralität das
heißt neutralität ist nicht
gleichzusetzen mit geht uns allen nichts
also sondern wir wollen keine partei
sein in einem konflikt also wir hatten
uns da immer raus wir greifen auch keine
partei aber das heißt nicht dass wir uns
dass wir keine positionen einnehmen also
wir haben zum beispiel ganz stark
vertreten wir die oder fördern und
unterstützen die menschenrechte weltweit
also wir sind dass er auf universalität
der menschenrechte aus ist auch ein
erklärtes außenpolitisches ziel und
daher wenn wir proteste einlegen
irgendwie in einem konfliktgebiet heißt
das nicht dass wir die neutralität
verletzt haben sondern gleichgültigkeit
ist nicht gleich neutralität die
vielleicht wichtigste frage die ich
heute auch den leuten auf der strasse
stelle ist was denken die deutschen über
die schweiz was wissen sie über die
schweiz was haben sie für vorteile was
haben sie für fakten die gleiche frage
würde ich ihn auch stellen und zwar aus
beiden perspektiven sie sind natürlich
schweizerin also vielleicht können sie
erst mal sagen was was sind was erleben
so sind sie in deutschland für
vorurteile oder für wissen auch über die
schweiz
mein eindruck ist eigentlich eher dass
die deutschen sich relativ wenig mit der
schweiz geschäftlich nicht so viel
wissen aber was sind so die die sachen
die sie hören was sind die sachen die in
velen und dann umgekehrt was was denken
die schweizer über die deutschen ja ich
denke sind so also überall vielleicht
die klischees oder weil man die schweiz
denkt kommen sicher zuerst mal
schokolade uhren berge
heidi so irgendwie diese all diese
klischees aber ich finde mich sehr stolz
dass wir ein sehr innovatives land sind
wir haben ja praktisch keine natürlichen
ressourcen außer wasser wir sind ein
wasser ressourcen land daher auch eine
energiequelle in europa aber ansonsten
haben wir keine ressourcen also keine
kohle oder es müssen wir alles mit brain
machen oder mit dem kopf und daher sind
wir stark auf bildung forschung
wir haben ausgezeichnete universitäten
und zum beispiel die eth zürich und
lausanne sind weltbekannt das sind
unsere technischen hochschulen und dort
entstehen sehr viele innovationen
beispiel was aus der schweiz kommt ist
das solarbetriebene flugzeug planet
solar und solar impuls als eines das
schiff und das andere flugzeug haben
aber miteinander einigen nicht zu tun
mit den urhebern aber das flugzeug das
ist ja dann gestartet und wollte die
welt umsegeln oder umfliegen ist dann in
japan jetzt zwischen stecken geblieben
wegen wegen dem wetter aber es ist ein
unglaublicher innovation dass ein
flugzeug nur mit sonnenenergie übung
rund um die welt fliegen kann und
eigentlich ohne halt könnte das machen
man muss nur unter weil der pilot sich
ausruhen muss aber dass die partie also
die solarzellen die die laden sich
ständig auf und das finde ich schon
enorm kommt aus der kleinen schweiz oder
und wir haben sehr viele solche
innovationen die wir auch aktiv werden
von der regierung aber auch natürlich
von der wirtschaft dass sie die
wirtschaft die firmen unterstützen auch
sehr viel innovation aber jetzt noch mal
zurück zu dem bild der deutschen was
also sie haben schon so die typischen
vorteile
oder die typischen bilder die man so im
kopf hat gesagt aber was glauben sie was
für ein gefühl haben die deutschen wenn
sie an die schweizer denken oder an die
schweiz also wie wie nehmen sie das hier
so weisen das positive ist dass eine
positive und negative eine gleichgültige
gibt es da viele freundschaften wie
nehmen sie das so war
also ich bin jetzt knapp drei monate
hier auf posten und ich war überwältigt
von den freundschaftlichen äußerung
gegenüber der schweiz dass man die
schweizer gern gehabt
das war für mich schon wirklich toll zu
hören war mir da nicht so bewusst und
umgekehrt
wie ist es umgekehrt für man kann es
sind natürlich alles generalisierung
aber wie glauben sie denken die
schweizer über die deutschen oder über
deutschland da gibt es auch viele
klischees oder das zum beispiel fußball
fußball auto was gibt's noch sicher auch
je nach region oder der barriere mieter
lederhose ich glaube das sind alles so
klischees wie es auf beiden seiten gibt
dann hört man doch auch oft der große
bruder oder aber sind also auch sehr
sehr freundschaftliche gefühle und ich
kenne kaum eine familie die nicht
irgendwo eine verbindung zu deutschland
hat also wir sind uns schon stehen uns
schon sehr nahe
es gibt gerade in letzter zeit ja viele
deutsche auch die in die schweiz ziehen
so wie mich wie glauben sie finden die
schweizer die entwicklung also ich meine
die schweiz ist immer schon
einwanderungsland vielleicht gewesen
oder vielleicht nicht immer schon aber
es ist auf jeden fall jetzt eine sehr
bunte nation mit vielen staub 25 prozent
ausländeranteil
aber ja gerade viele deutsche kommen hin
da kann man gutes geld verdienen wie
nehmen die schweizer das war so sagt wir
zu schenken gehören haben wir offene
grenzen und damit eben auch viel mehr
einwanderung aus europa und das ist für
die schweizer etwas neu aber nur für
diese generation einig wenn man
zurückblickt
da bist das schon in größerem maße also
etwa circa 19 15 hat ds prozentual mehr
deutsche in der schweiz als jetzt im
moment wohnen etwa 290.000 deutsche in
der schweiz bei einer einwohnerzahl von
etwa 86 millionen ist auch das eine
recht große zahl aber 19.15 hatten wir
schon 220.000 wobei die einwohnerzahl
noch viel kleiner war also eigentlich
ist das kein neues phänomen aber für die
vielleicht jetzige generation ist das
neu
ich denke wegen der sprache ist das
vielleicht so dass wir das wehr dass das
mehr auffällt weil wir sprechen ja nicht
so wie ich jetzt mit ihm spreche in der
schweiz an wir haben das schweizer team
und das verstehen die deutschen
anscheinend nicht das war das ist uns
auch oft nicht so bewusst weil wir
denken das ist ja wie deutsch also je
versteht das doch aber ich glaube die
erfahrungen haben sie sicher in basel
gemacht dass das sehr schwer zu
verstehen ist obwohl an der grenze her
dass noch viel verständlicher ist je
weiter sie in die berge gehen wird
schwieriger das zu verstehen und daher
fällt fällt halt auch ein deutscher
bürger in der schweiz schnell auf aber
dass ich die haben zu integrieren gibt
der nicht bis sie das demselben
kulturkreis also wir sind auch froh für
für fachkräfte die bei uns arbeit suchen
jetzt haben sie eine sehr gute
überleitung gemacht denn das letzte
große thema was ich von ihnen ja mit
ihnen herausfinden möchte ist eben das
schweizer wünscht wie erklärt man
vielleicht auch jemanden der mit beiden
ländern nichts zu tun hat der deutsch
lernt dieses schwyzerdütsch das ist ja
nicht nur ein dialekt sowie bayerisch
oder sächsisch sondern das ist ja
eigentlich eine eigene sprache fast
schon aber es ist auch nicht eine eigene
sprache weil es ja ganz viele
unterschiedliche schweizer deutsche
dialekte gibt also wie würden sie das
erklären erst mal was ist das
schwyzerdütsch
also es ist schon eine sprache aber eben
es wird nur gesprochen wir schreiben die
sprache nicht so wie wir sprechen die
jungen machen das zwar so wie bei den
sms das wird auf schweizerdeutsch so wie
man es spricht wird einfach geschrieben
es gibt aber keine regeln aber wir
müssen hoch deutsch in der schule lernen
als er spätestens in der ersten klasse
müssen wir im unterricht hochdeutsch
sprechen aber das für uns eigentlich
eine fremdsprache weil wir so ja zu
hause nicht sprechen
und jeder kanton hat einen anderen
dialekt also ich höre dass sofort aus
welchem kanton jemand kommt und da
gibt's schon sehr eigenheiten also zum
beispiel im kanton wallis für zuhörer
oder zuschauer
das ist der kanton wo das matterhorn ist
das ist oft ein kanton der umgeben ist
von bergen
also ist der dialekt noch viel
ursprünglicher geblieben und konnte sich
vielleicht weniger anpassen an andere
sprachen und dort gibt es für die worte
die wie in zürich brauchen ganz andere
ausdrücke sind sie ursprünglich aus
zürich ich bin ursprünglich wollen sie
mal walliser verheiratet ok wollen sie
mal vielleicht zwei drei sätze auf
deutsch sagen dass das unsere zuschauer
dass man schon mal einen vorgeschmack
bekommen wie sich das anhört
mir redet ihm züge ganz anders aus einem
haufen wallis rund und im wallis tobias
wallisser treten und kärnten hat ganz
ein anderer ausdruck rasse zum beispiel
fürs 2 v.li
seit man hintritt schwein und der
walliser seite im schwarz weiß ich nicht
ob sie das verstanden haben doch nach
drei monaten in basel verstrich das
mittlerweile gut aber letztens habe ich
jemanden getroffen aus beeren und da
hatte ich dann auch schon meine
schwierigkeiten das ist dann doch noch
mal ein bisschen was anderes
würden sie denn leuten empfehlen wenn
sie die schweiz ziehen diesen dialekt zu
lernen und damit meine ich eben nicht
nur verstehen lernen sondern auch
sprechen zu lernen ist es überhaupt
möglich kennen sie jemanden der das
geschafft hat
ich kenne ein paar aber sind wirklich
ganz wenige wahrscheinlich sehr
sprachbegabt weil man hört immer so wie
man mir anhört dass ich nicht aus
deutschland bin meiner kinder die in
einer mehrheitlich deutschen schule zum
unterricht ging weil wir immer im
ausland waren die die lachen mich immer
noch außen sagen mama so kannst um
möglichen deutschland arbeiten
man hört von kilometer an dass du aus
der schweiz kommst ich glaube man kann
das gar nicht ganz ablegen und daher ist
es aber genauso schwierig
schweizerdeutsch zu sprechen ohne dass
man hört dass es eigentlich angelernt
ist zb meine schwiegermutter kam aus
deutschland aus münster und jetzt schon
gar nicht versucht zu lernen ich komme
auch aus müsste ich bin da geboren und
ich habe mit ihr natürlich immer
hochdeutsch gesprochen und aber ich fand
dass angst das fand ich ganz normal dass
sie das gar nicht versucht zu lernen das
hätte man sowieso gehört aber glauben
sie dass es für die schweizer
anstrengend ist hochdeutsch zu sprechen
also es ist einfacher schweizerdeutsch
zu sprechen weil ich ja ich denke für
viele ist es eine herausforderung eine
rede auf hochdeutsch zu halten oder ein
vortrag zu halten auf deutsch oder sich
im mit mit journalisten zu unterhalten
es ist für viele eine anstrengende sache
also ich habe das so gehört für mich ich
bin mir sehr gewohnt aber für viele ist
es schon ein sich anstrengen
ich möchte sie nicht soviel zeit klar
würde nur noch interessieren mich will
noch interessieren gibt es dinge die die
sie gerne den leuten beibringen würde
über die schweizer da wo sie sagen hey
das ist was das weiter das wissen die
leute nicht über die schweiz oder
mainland oder was sind wir haben über
die vorurteile gesprochen aber was sind
vielleicht was ist jemand was ist etwas
was niemand weiß was eigentlich jeder
wissen sollte
also was ist schon erwähnt habe ist eben
die forschung innovation das sind wir
wirklich sehr stark dass es eben nicht
nur es geht nicht nur käse und
schokolade sondern wir haben da wirklich
eine tolle forschungs maschinerie und
das ist sicher nicht so bekannt
vielleicht auch etwas das jetzt im
moment sehr aktuell ist mit der
migrationspolitik vielleicht auch vielen
nicht bekannt dass wir 25 prozent der
schweizer sie der bevölkerung in der
schweiz sind ausländer
und dass wir eigentlich ein tolerantes
und offenes land sind weil wir schon
immer mit migration konfrontiert werden
und versuchen möglichst die leute zu
integrieren was wie hoffe dass das uns
gelingen mag das kann ich vielleicht
nochmal erzählen so zum abschluss als
ich nach basel gezogen bin habe ich
einen brief bekommen mit einer einladung
zu einer willkommens veranstaltung im
basler rathaus und da war ich wirklich
beeindruckt es war ein
eine große veranstaltung mit mehreren
hundert zugezogenen wo es zunächst so
ein paar kurze reden gab von
verschiedenen menschen von verschiedenen
ämtern diesen überblick gegeben haben
wir für sie da sind und dann sind wir
alle zusammen auf einem boot gegangen
auf ein schiff im rhein sind eine stunde
den rhein hoch und runtergefahren mit
apéro also mit kostenlosen getränken und
häppchen und dazu gab es im stände von
den ganzen verschiedenen ämtern wo man
sich informieren konnte und ausländer
beratung und was ist alles gab und das
fand ich so fantastisch wie herzlich
willkommen geheißen wird wirklich auch
und ja integriert wird ich glaube in
deutschland denn wenn jemand nach berlin
zieht der wird nicht eingeladen zu so
einem fest auf einem boot auf der spree
wo er einen ganzen abend weiß wein
trinkt und sich dazu informieren kann
also das habe ich noch nie erlebt anders
war ja also ich glaube wirklich dass wir
da schon in vielen bereichen in der
integration voraussehen
wird diese situation schon länger kennen
und wir haben einfach gemerkt
integration ist die beste möglichkeit um
eine ein friedliches zusammenleben zu
haben und wo dann auch gegen
fremdenfeindlichkeit dagegen angekämpft
werden kann also je mehr nie mehr man
sich kennt desto besser ist das
zusammenleben und ich glaube das fängt
schon in kleinen dingen an
ich sage immer wenn wenn man den
nachbarn kennt dann stört es viel
weniger wenn er seinen zaun nicht immer
zurückschneidet also so geht es auch mit
der integration der ausländer wenn man
sich kennt dann sind das plötzlich
freunde und das wünschte ich mir dass
wir friedlich zusammenleben können
das ein sehr schönes schlusswort vielen
dank dass sie sich da die zeit genommen